autour des années 1600 galilée monta en
haut de la tour de pise
pour l'une des premières démonstrations
d'expériences scientifiques de
l'histoire de là haut
kelly les laissa tomber deux boules de
poids différents alors que le public
s'attendait à voir la bouille la plus
lourde de tomber plus vite la surprise
générale les deux boulets tenir le sol
en même temps bon j'ai fait l'expérience
et sait pas ce que j'ai vu à l'école
vous vie que si on fait l'expérience on
est censé conclure que tous les objets
tombent à la même vitesse c'est la loi
de la shooter des corps de galilée nous
dit on sauf que sauf que c'est faux si
on fait l'expérience on voit la bouille
le plus lourd de tomber plus vite
et du coup on ne peut pas conclure
qu'ils les avaient tous à la même
vitesse alors à l'école toujours on nous
dit que si on obligeait plus lourd ton
plus vite c'est à cause des frottements
de l'air qui affecte mois son mouvement
que celui du de l'objet plus léger et ça
c'est complètement juste si on prend
deux boules et qu'on fait le vide
complet qu'on enlève tous leurs qui en
dessous d'elle eh ben les deux boules
vont tomber exactement la même vitesse
c'est l'expérience qu'a fait brian cox
pour la bbc
mais pour l'expérience de la bbc pour un
coq salut utiliser des moyens faramineux
qu'il a dû avoir une tour énorme et
faire un vide
excellent l'intérieur de cette tour
chose que gainey ne sont jamais pu faire
elle avait juste pas les moyens
techniques de faire ça mais en fait ce
n'est pas en jetant des moules de très
haut que galilée a découvert sa loi de
la chute des corps
en fait l'histoire de la tour de pise et
complètement inventée de toutes pièces
sans doute par l'étudiant de galilée
pour vulgariser sa loi de la chute des
cornes et quand on y réfléchit c'est
forcément une histoire inventée en effet
s'il avait fait l'expérience
kelly les aurait vus l'objet le plus
lourd ton décrue vite confirmant ainsi
la théorie dominante de la chute des
corps à l'époque on considérait
qu'aristote était le plus courant savant
de tous les temps et aristote avait
affirmé que des objets plus lourd tomber
plus vite et c'était tout sauf des bills
puisque l'expérience confirmée les lois
d'aristote et du coup si qualité n'a pas
fait l'expérience de la tour de pise
comment at il pu oser réfléter la pensée
d'aristote
comment at il pu prétendre que les
objets ton tous à la même vitesse s'il
n'a jamais fait d'expérience pour le
prouver directement et surtout comment
il a fini par croire en sa loi pourquoi
est ce qu'il a pensé ce qu'il a pensé
lorsque je trouve vraiment triste c'est
que ce n'est que récemment des années
après mai dernier cours de physique que
j'ai découvert enfant des réponses
satisfaisantes à ces questions l'école
pendant 20 ans n'a jamais su mon seigner
la vraie raison pour laquelle kelly les
était persuadé de sa loi et en gros ou
pas avancé quatre explications
pour commencer les lits les a bel et
bien fait des expériences de chute des
corps ce qui fut remarquable c'est que
plus le vide est évident - la différence
entre la chute d'une balle et d'une
plume était grande
il semblait que si le vide était parfait
la différence aurait pu être nul mais ça
ça provient pour commencer les difficile
de prouver qu'elle deux objets tombent
au sol en même temps exactement
et puis surtout on peut toujours
rétorquer que la hauteur de chute
n'était pas assez grande pour voir une
différence
vous savez si vous prenez une pomme une
pastèque et que vous les laissez tomber
de cette hauteur là ils vont arriver au
sol à peu près en même temps
mais si on fait ça du haut de la tour de
peilz de la tour eiffel avant la
pastèque va tomber au sol plus vite
galilée étudie alors la chute de boules
le loup de plan incliné
la chute des boules et en plus lente
galilée réussi à mieux comparer la chute
de deux boules différentes elles étaient
quasi identiques par ailleurs kelly les
remarques à caen deux fois plus de temps
la balle parcours est quatre fois plus
de distance
voilà qui montrait que la vitesse de la
balle augmentait
la balle accélère oui mais là les moules
elle roule du coup elle tourne pas
vraiment du coup c'est pas forcément
exactement le même phénomène physique et
puis on peut aussi dire que lorsqu on
fait ça on prend des boules qui ont
toujours une différence de poids qui est
pas si grande que ça et que peut-être
que différence de mesures qu'on observe
qu'une quasi nul et seulement casier
parce qu'on a pris débrouille qui ont à
peu près le même poids
galilée étudie aussi les trajectoires
des boulets de canon dont les enjeux
militaires étaient cruciaux galilée
découvrit ainsi que ses trajectoires
étaient parabolique
mieux encore il remarqua que ces
trajectoires correspondait à une
accélération constante vers le bas et
que ses trajectoires étaient les mêmes
pour tous les boulets de canon et même
pour d'autres objets comme les fontaines
à peu près voilà qui suggérait que tous
tombés avec même accélération d'environ
10 mètres par seconde en plus par
seconde ça commence à devenir
convaincant tant d'un point de vue
mathématique c'est ça c'est joli mais
c'est pas décisif encore simplement
conclusive de gagner est un tout autre
argument qui aimait donner moi mon
préféré s'agit d'un argument implacable
et d'un argument purement théorique qui
consiste à prouver qu'elle a loix
qu'aristote on ne peut pas être vrai que
ce soit d'autres univers comme dans
n'importe quel autre univers la loi
d'aristote est forcément fausse l'idée
géniale de galilée fut de considérer la
chute de deux coureurs différents
attachés l'un à l'autre disons que l'on
a par exemple attaché une pastèque à une
pomme avec un fil
question la pastèque attaché à la pomme
tombera-t-elle plus vite ou moins vite
que la pastèque seul
et là où galilée est vraiment malin
c'est que plutôt que de chercher à
utiliser sa loi de la chute des corps
pour répondre à cette question il va
chercher à déterminer les prédictions
que font la loi d'aristote
celle qui dit que les objets plus lourd
tombe plus vite d'un côté la pastèque
plus la pomme forment un système plus
lourd que la pastèque seul
d'après la loi d'aristote c'est donc la
pastèque attaché à la pomme qui doit
tomber plus vite que la pastèque seul
mais d'un autre côté la pastèque attaché
à la pomme est attaché un objet plus
léger qu'elle
d'après la loi d'aristote la pastèque va
tomber plus vite que la pomme
si bien que la pomme va être amené à
freiner la chute de la pastèque tel un
parachute la pastèque et donc freiner
dans sa chute elle tombe donc moins vite
que si elle tombait seule la loi
d'aristote prédit donc une chose et son
contraire
elle est donc forcément inconsistante
incroyable avec une expérience de pensée
lumineuse d'une minute seulement que
j'ai pu vous expliquer juste la galilée
a démontré une fois et pour tout que la
loi de la chute des corps d'aristote
était forcément fausse et par conséquent
les objets les plus lourds ne tombe pas
plus vite
tous les objets tombent en fait avec la
même accélération et le plus fou dans
tout ça c'est que galilée l'a prouvé
indépendamment de toute expérience
pire que ça kelly les l'a prouvé malgré
l'expérience et ça ça doit vous faire
réfléchir à ce que l'on appelle
l'épistémologie c'est à dire la manière
dont on finit par savoir des choses
parmi les pires criminelle de la cour de
justice des sciences on trouve les
théories complotistes du web
les expériences personnelles ce que
j'irai passer la nuit dernière et tout
en bas on trouve les théories
inconsistante à qui on a réservé la
peine capitale
cette théorie inconsistante ont été
abattus à jamais par les sciences car
elles sont pires que archi fausse note
even vang comme le disait le physicien
wolfgang pauli pour ridiculiser bon
nombre de théories pseudo-scientifiques
une théorie inconsistante ne sera j
à mesvres peu importe la montagne de
preuves que vous aurez pour la défendre
est ce que je trouve vraiment dommage
c'est qu'à l'école on insiste quasiment
jamais sur l'importance de la
consistance des théories notamment dans
la méthode scientifique dont galilée
serait le père
pourtant si galilée a découvert ces lois
c'est rarement à l'aide de la méthode
scientifique le plus souvent notamment à
travers cette fameuse expérience de
pensée
kelly les a simplement cherché à
garantir autant que possible la
consistance la clarté et la simplicité
de ses théories que ce soit pour la loi
de la chute des corps
le principe de relativité ou
l'héliocentrisme les observations les
expériences n'était ensuite que
davantage d'arguments pour confirmer ou
réfuter telle ou telle théorie et quand
je dis tout ça j'ai aussi en tête la
théorie de l'évolution de darwin
la raison principale pour laquelle j'y
crois n'a rien à voir avec les
observations
si j'y crois c'est surtout parce qu'il
s'agit d'une théorie merveilleusement
consistante bon surtout avec la
découverte de l'adn mais aussi et
surtout ultra limpide et incroyablement
simple pour bien sûr et découvert des
fossiles la phylogénie et la génétique
contribuer à rendre la théorie d'autant
plus crédible mais je pense que si on
raisonnait uniquement en termes de
consistance a consisté en citant les
plus importants mais aussi en termes de
clarté de simplicité des théories on
conclurait avait immédiatement que tout
un tas de théories pseudo scientifiques
sont clairement sans intérêt comme par
exemple la loi de la chute des corps
d'aristote l'interphone à parler de dieu
maître hyperbolique
et vous aviez des questions et les
remarques très intéressante à ce sujet
notamment celle de guillaume guillaume
s'oppose à quillan de la formule 2
du périmètre d'un cercle en géométrie
hyperbolique je vais vous donner en
géométrie hyperbolique et en géométrie
sphérique publiques classiques et avant
de faire ça il faut que je vous parle de
distance caractéristiques quand
géométrie sphérique on définit souvent
la distance caractéristiques comme étant
le rayon de la sphère en géométrie
hyperbolique c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué mais on peut la dédiant fait
de la courbure gaussienne fait la
courbure gaussienne termes d'unités sa
date du 1 / m² du maître puissance - 2
donc si on prend la racine carrée de 1 /
- cas où la racine carrée de rein sur
cassure géométrie hausse ric var on va
avoir une distance vous rappelez rc
distance caractéristiques
donc si j'appelle le petit air
l'oreillon du cercle en géométrie
sphérique un cercle de rayon petit air
va voir pour périmètre tout fois
grand-père fois le sinus de petit air
son grand-père un géomètre guyenne c'est
juste la formule t'offre petit air comme
nous l'apprend et en géométrie
hyperbolique ça va être tout fois
grand-père pour le sinus hyperbolique de
paix diverses augmentèrent donc le signe
ici verbe olic
si vous connaissez pas je vous invite à
aller voir la page wikipédia en gros
c'est juste la version exponentielle du
sinus donc ces formules en fait elles
sont valables si on est en géométrie
parfaitement sphérique au parfaitement
hyperbolique quand on va parler de
relativité générale on va voir des
espaces qui sont ni totalement
hyperbolique ni totalement ce ferry qui
sont parfois asphériques à certains
endroits parfois hyperbolique à d'autres
temps puis ça va dépendre la direction
de secours est en dimension supérieure
et du coup si on parle de géométrie
localement sur les coûts localement
hyperbolique ce qui va importer ça va
être le développement limité de tout ça
donc le développement imitée j'en étais
apparaît dans une vidéo précédente et si
vous faites le développement illimité de
ceux ci vous voyez qu'il ya le kart 2
de courbure qui va être quasiment tel
quel dans cette formule est en tout cas
vous voyez même apparaître au 3éme ordre
la différence entre les jeunes les trois
jours mitri avec la valeur de cas qui
apparaît à chaque fois donc si vous
voulez comprendre la courbure de façon
de vraiment comprendre complètement la
courbure c'est de regarder ces
développements limitée des périmètres
des cercles et voir comment il augmente
en fonction du rayon du cirque en
question j'ai aussi une entame de match
et leonetti qui semble voir lien entre
des géométries père vic les équations
différentielles c'est en effet en effet
un lien qui étaient découverts par
poincaré et je vous renvoie vers la
vidéo de tianjin à ce sujet parce que
moi je ne maîtrise pas totalement et
enfin j'ai un message très sympa des
services qui a aimé ma vidéo ce qui la
fait super plaisir
il a tout même signaler une erreur que
j'ai fait j'ai dit que je mettrais
hyperbolique les droite avait tendance à
toujours ce éloignées les unes des
autres ce que j'avais en tête c'est pas
mal si à un moment où droite de droite
sont parallèles et 20 où elles vont
finir par s'éloigner mais ils existent
comme le fait remarquer était de 10 des
droites en géométrie hyperbolique qui
vont avoir tendance à toujours se
rapprocher donc peu importe là où vous
regardez à les enfants va se rapprocher
mais elle ne se confrontent j'avais donc
se rapprocheront de façon asymptomatique
comme ça mais enfin qu'il s'agit des
droites que j'ai dessiné quand j'ai
parlé de triangle idéaux fait les droits
de biétry en griot sont justement des
droites qui se rapprochent
asymptotiquement je suis désolé pour
cette petite erreur et je pense que
c'est une erreur qui est assez cool
avoir fait et surtout à avoir corrigé
aller j'espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'une
théorie est plus ou moins crédibles
je vous invite à mettre ce que vous
pensez dans les commentaires la
prochaine fois on parlera de
l'égocentrisme qui vraiment ou par mail
autour de cette question de caisse qui
bonne théorie si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à tout ce qui pourrait
l'aimer
aussi en partageant cette vidéo metella
des pousses vers l'eau et mettez des
commentaires ça me fera super plaisir
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et j'espère
qu'elle vous verrez vous connaissez la
légende c'est une légende
la tour de pise est un grand pipeau
historique
imaginez galilée monter au sommet la
troupe et aux pistes pour lancer des
boules de pétanque en même temps que des
balles de tennis crs et
rétrospectivement risible vous
l'imaginez convoqué tous les sorbonnards
de l'époque qui sont restés lyciens il
fait tomber les boules de pétanque en
même temps qu'elle a douté il
aristotélicien voit que les boules de
pétanque touche le sol avant les balles
de tennis et 10
on le savait déjà donc si vous faites
l'expérience de la tour de pise sa
confiance
aristote mais galilée sur ce coup là il
n'observe pas il fait une expérience de
pensée et si on reliait un objet lourd
un objet de léger par une ficelle